all right so just to let you know i'm
not going to talk spoilers in here this
is a spoiler-free review however i will
touch on some things that were seen in
the second trailer which i hadn't seen
so i was like does everybody know that
it's in the second trailer so you've
seen the second trailer i'm not spilling
anything new also there's one thing in
here again i was like how much can i
talk about that in interviews with the
actor they freely talk about it so there
is that so yeah not spoilers i just want
to warn you as to what spectrum of
information i'm pulling from and it is
information that's out there that's not
considered spoilers per the filmmaker of
the film little double speaks trip me up
anyhow let's go
[Music]
so the matrix resurrections is the
fourth film in the matrix franchise and
the trailers while i didn't see the
second one but the first trailer i
thought was pretty extraordinary in
terms of how trailers go great song
choice great editing to go with the
music i was intrigued it had my
curiosity and then the movie started and
the entire beginning of this movie is
recreating literally recreating the
opening scene in the first matrix movie
i was like oh is that how it's going to
be it's just going to be nostalgia bait
member berry pie
what kind of a lot a lot of this movie
is that we're first going to talk about
what i liked in this movie jessica
henwick i liked her a lot i really liked
her character she's a character that's
easy for me to like you know she's like
nope this is the mission we got to find
and help neil she's a pain in the ass to
her superiors who feel like no she
shouldn't do this thing she's like well
screw you i'm gonna do it anyway i like
characters like that i liked her in the
movie she's actually a really big
standout in here also goes without say
but it's great to see keanu back i mean
it's great to see keanu and carrie anne
moss but there's this build to it you
know neither of them remembers the
events of before but there's a strong
connection between the two i'll say that
about this movie in concept i'm going to
say that a lot there's there's a lot in
concept that works in here as some
really interesting concepts and ideas
it's different than sticking the landing
but a concept they definitely had in
here is the concept that there's this
connection between neo and trinity
because in the matrix reloaded when
colonel sanders is breaking it down he's
talking about neo's motivation for
saving the human race is very focused
it's love it's love for trinity this
movie did its best to drive you to the
point of like okay these two really mean
a lot they have a love that transcends
life death and any version of the matrix
very love conquers all the refuse scenes
in here where something happened and i
just thought of the power of love
the visuals in this movie were cool
they're fine not groundbreaking like the
first matrix maybe that's just the fact
of any matrix movie the matrix changed
sci-fi
at minimum and cinema in reality it's
like movies changed after the matrix
this isn't going to have that effect
short of like plugging the entire
audience into an actual matrix for them
to experience this movie it's not going
to be that however if you look at the
original matrix not only in some of the
fight scenes or their long shots of just
fists going back and forth uncut but
also shots that look like they were
pulled from a graphic novel like you
could pull that shot put it in a graphic
novel or a comic book and you're like oh
yeah visually
same energy as they say even the matrix
reloaded in revolutions like visually
speaking had some really cool stuff that
stood out this movie just you know felt
like an action movie in 2021 looked cool
had some really cool scenes maybe we've
seen it all but maybe that's why they
shouldn't make a fourth matrix movie now
the premise of the matrix this reality
within reality
lends itself to being self-aware and
meta and self-aware and meta this movie
is this is a very self-aware and meta
movie one of the most self-aware meta
i've ever seen i've seen it compared to
wes craven's new nightmare different
thing it's not like keanu reeves plays
keanu reeves
and he was once neo and he has to
re-figure that out keanu reeves plays a
software developer who created a trilogy
of games called that's right the matrix
the premise lends itself to being
self-aware absolutely but i think it
does it to its detriment it just
beats it over your head the point that
this movie is self-aware of the matrix
there's even a monologue someone has
with him is like oh we need to make a
fourth matrix warner brother says it's
going to happen with or without us and
at a point it just kind of felt like a
wachowski vanity project there were so
many meta references in this movie that
the audience i was with was laughing it
i don't know that the matrix is supposed
to feel like a comedy but at a point it
did it breached that meta line to be
like okay we're going for laughs now and
we are a comedy i give this movie credit
for addressing how the world changed
after the events of the original matrix
trilogy it's not like okay matrix is
happening again it takes place after the
third one
everything they did was [ __ ] it
didn't amount to anything there is
definitely it amounted to something i
appreciate that that's actually one of
the things i find most interesting about
this world seeing how the world changed
how it's different how the matrix is
dealt with differently how robots in our
world and robots and that world and
humans in our world and humans in that
world like there's a different dynamic
there i probably appreciate that most
about this movie because that is the
film looking forward not looking back i
mean granted they do quickly look back
after moments like that it's like yes
here's the present look into the future
and that happened because the original
matrix trilogy speaking of the original
matrix trilogy uh remember that you
remember i remember great remember the
original matrix trilogy because it was
great and that we need you to remember
that and how that was great in order to
assess how this is great i suppose one
of the reasons the whole self-aware meta
thing this movie was going for started
to wear on me is because the movie was
joking about it then it became that
which it was joking about ironically or
unironically other than the fact that
when new morpheus is talking to neo he
has b-roll footage of the original
matrix of morpheus talking to neo on a
projector in the background but there
are things with the characters i don't
understand why they felt they had to do
that yaya abdul martin ii being morpheus
i there's a story based reason as to why
he is morpheus and how he is morpheus
but i never felt like he had to be
morpheus he could have just been a new
character if you want to have morpheus
back you can bring lawrence fishburne
back as morpheus you don't have to have
canonically killed him in the matrix
online i don't even know if that's how
he went down it's just like he's not in
the movie i don't know that he died in
the matrix online and that's what this
movie's going off of and this is where
it's not spoilerish it was in the second
trailer and in interviews with the actor
but so i'm going to talk about it if you
don't want to know you've been warned
but yaya abdul martin ii being morpheus
is how i felt about jonathan groff being
smith it's like these characters could
have been new characters it's fine to
have new characters maybe they saw how
unmemorable the new characters were in
this movie because you have a new ship a
new crew as i call them jessica henwick
and other people because she's the one
who stands out maybe there was a freak
out moment where they're like ah we need
to i don't know just make them
characters that people know but new
smith doesn't embody agent smith at all
yaya abdul martin the second it's like
oh yeah that's morpheus he does feel
like the character more than new smith
feels like the character news like from
the trailer when you see him say mr
anderson
it doesn't feel like hugo weaving which
is a disservice to the character the
film and the actor jonathan groff the
actor could have been a new character a
new character who stood out he could
have done everything he actually did in
this movie just don't make him smith
because when you make him smith now i'm
comparing him to hugo weaving so he's
doomed to live in hugo weaving shadow
and that just that sucks the matrix
resurrections works too hard to recreate
things you've already seen in the other
matrix movies like when neo's fighting
the new smith character there are these
pillars i literally i in my head clock i
went and smith is gonna punch the pillar
and take a chunk out of it in three two
one
on cue of course he did because he did
that in the first matrix movie why
wouldn't they do that here why wouldn't
they recreate it in the end the matrix
resurrections had interesting concepts
but it's cheapened under being buried
under a metric ton of nostalgia bait
funny enough in my spiderman no way home
spoiler talks is a very it's a very
nostalgic week for film goers but in my
spiderman no way home spoiler talk i
talked about how that movie had
nostalgia but made it work for the
narrative so going on to this fresh off
of that it just felt like the matrix
resurrections went too far into the
cheap nostalgia base and i feel like the
matrix resurrections is just six years
too late i've heard this movie compared
to the last jedi i wouldn't say the last
jedi the force awakens absolutely that's
why i say this movie six years too late
if it was 2015 i probably would have
just gobbled this up i'd be like yeah
force awakens member berry pie and
matrix and it's so awesome in nostalgia
but it's six years later and i'm kind of
over it i do can see there very well
might be some super high concepts that
i'm missing or multiple viewings
necessary probably i only saw the movie
once i mean shoot the matrix reloaded
and resurrections took me time to
appreciate so who knows but for my money
right now i will say this movie's
probably a better time if you're drunk
that's really not going to help yeah
you're right who am i kidding probably a
better time if you're high yeah now it's
a party all right so the matrix
resurrections have you seen it are you
gonna see it are you looking forward to
it it's on hbo max as well as movie
theater so however you want to watch it
but whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you